nevertheless by multiplying these closed Loops of x Errors By X stabilizer generators they can effectively be shrunk down to
nothing and it's certainly True by the way that we can only get loops like this by multiplying together X stabilizer generators because every X stabilizer
generator puts an even number of X operations on every horizontal line and on every vertical
line the other type of closed loop we can have is one that crosses at least one line an odd number of times such as
the one that's shown here which crosses every horizontal line just once and here's another example that crosses
each vertical line just once so these are examples of non-trivial errors that go undetected by the code but the key
here is that the only way to form a closed loop like this is to go around the Taurus either around the hole in the
middle of the Taurus or through the hole or it could be both this is a topological property
concerning aurus it's all about the holes basically and that's why this is called a topological Quantum error Cor
code in terms of this visualization of a two-dimensional lattice with periodic boundaries a chain in this category must
loop around one or both of the periodic boundaries in a way that makes it impossible to contract that Loop to a
point by multiplying it by X stabilizer generators such a chain might be more
complicated than the one that's Illustrated here but this is the shortest that such a loop can possibly be because it has to somehow loop around
one or both of the periodic bound boundaries and what this implies is that the minimum weight of a non-trivial
undetectable error is L any closed loop with fewer errors than that must fall into the first category and is therefore
in the stabilizer and chains of errors that don't form closed Loops are detected by the code and that's it that's why this code
works and what we end up with is a 2 l^2 2 L stabilizer code we're using 2 L S
cubits to code 2 cubits and the code has distance L next I'll say just a little bit about
correcting errors with the Torah code though I won't go too far into the details if we measure the syndrome and
we see something other than the all plus1 syndrome where I'm speaking here about just the Z stabilizer generators
then the minus one outcomes indicate to us the end points of one or more chains of adjacent X errors and we can attempt to correct
these Errors By pairing together the minus one outcomes and forming a chain of X Corrections between them and as
we're doing this it makes sense to choose shortest paths for our Corrections for example if we measure a
syndrome such as the one that's shown here then we could choose this path between the unhappy tiles and apply X
Gates as Corrections along this path of course the actual chain of Errors causing the syndrome could have
been different such as the one that's shown here but that's okay as as long as the errors and the corrections together
fall into the stabilizer it could also be that our Corrections complete a loop around the
Taurus which is bad because in doing this we've caused a logical error so this strategy of correcting
along shortest paths corrects low weight errors but it might not work for higher weight errors but of course we can't
expect anything more from any Quantum error cting code more likely perhaps depending upon the noise model is that
we observe a bunch of minus ones in the syndrome and in this case we can use efficient classical algorithms to help
us to pair them up and find a lowest weight error representing the syndrome as I mentioned in the previous
lesson this may not always correct the most likely explanation for the syndrome but it does work pretty well in general
and it always succeeds in correcting errors having weight strictly less than half the distance L and I should also
mention that there are other strategies that are better Suited Ed to different error models it's been over 25 years since the
Tor code was discovered and in that time there's been quite a lot of work on Quantum error correcting codes including
other topological Quantum error correcting codes inspired by the Torah code as well as codes based on different
ideas I certainly can't give you a comprehensive list of all of the different code constructions that are known but I will scratch the surface
just a little bit and briefly mention a couple of well-known examples first as a turns out it isn't
really essential that the Tor code has periodic boundaries that is it's possible to cut out just a portion of the Tor code and
lay it flat on a two-dimensional surface rather than on a Taurus and what we get by doing that is called a surface
code for instance if we cut the edges of a lattice in the pattern that's shown here with so-called rough edges at the
top and bottom and smooth edges at the sides and correspondingly we include edge cases for the stabilizer generators
then we end up with a code that can encode just one Cub at this time but the code nevertheless inherits the most
important characteristics of the Tor code in particular non-trivial undetectable errors for this code must
correspond to chains of errors that either stretch from the left Edge to the right Edge or from the top to the bottom
depending on whether they're chains of X errors or Z errors respectively it's also possible to cut
the edges diagonally to obtain what are sometimes called rotated service codes and doing that can be helpful for making
the codes more economical in terms of how many cubits are used for example if we take this surface
code and we throw away some of the cubits leaving a square oriented diagonally we obtain another service
code so long as we specify the stabilizer generators on the boundary in the right way diagrams like this are
helpful for making clear how the stabilizer generators are defined where black tiles including the rounded ones at the edges indicate X stabilizer
generators and the white ones indicate Z stabilizer generators the ones on the boundary by the way are just 2 Cubit XX
or ZZ stabilizer generators this time and you'll commonly see these diagrams rotated by
45° another interesting class of codes which also fall into the general category of topological codes are color
codes I won't explain exactly how they work but one way to think about them is that they're geometric generalizations
of the 7 Cubit steam code so let's consider the seven cubits team code and suppose that we number our
cubits using the KCET ordering Convention as is shown here on the screen we can then associate these seven
cubits with the vertices of the graph that's shown here and what we find is that the stabilizer generators match up
with the tiles or the faces that are formed by the edges of the graph and for each tile we always have a z stabilizer
generator and an X stabilizer generator that act non-trivially on precisely those cubits that are found at the vertices of that